in this video we're going to talk about
a highly controversial subject the idea
that we can deliberately change the
world's climate to combat the effects of
global warming and this idea is called
geoengineering and in addition to this
video which is going to focus more on
the physics of how geoengineering works
I highly recommend that you check out my
friend feathers video series on the
subject he's been doing a whole bunch of
different videos on different techniques
that we could use to this end and go
check them out because they're pretty
awesome and I've been doing a little bit
of work on them fact-checking samba Suns
so yeah they're pretty cool last time we
extensively looked at global warming and
climate change and found that the
observed warming over the past century
or so is directly linked to co2 levels
in the atmosphere now the more carbon
dioxide there is in the atmosphere the
less energy that the earth emits into
space causing an energy imbalance which
results in the earth warming now that
description of global warming suggests
two different solutions to the problem
so let's look at those one at a time
solution 1 the energy imbalance which is
causing the warming is itself caused by
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere so to
reduce the amount of warming let's
remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere solution to the earth is
emitting less energy into space than it
used to while the amount of energy that
it receives from the Sun has remained
constant ish so to remove the energy
imbalance let's reduce the amount of
energy that the earth is absorbing from
the Sun now both of these solutions
probably ranked on the plausibility
scale whew somewhere between impractical
and absolutely insane but a huge amount
of research has been done on the subject
and it's more possible than you're
probably thinking now one of the people
doing the research on the subject is my
colleague Angus Ferraro who's an
associate research fellow here at the
University of Exeter and I interviewed
him all about the topic so over trying
this to talk about the first of these
solutions so that's the easiest thing to
do that's probably what people would say
is like well why can't we just create a
giant some kind of catalytic thing that
will just you know blow air through and
suck carbon dioxide out of the air and
in in theory that's quite possible and
it can be done right now in fact it's
being done right now there's there are
some companies that construct these kind
of weird wonderful machines that do this
it's a really cool one it basically
looks like a giant Bank of jet engines
and all its doing is blowing air over
this stuff which chemically removes co2
from the atmosphere the main problem
with that is that the energy
requirements for something like that are
very very large and that makes it very
expensive some of the more weird wind
wonderful proposals for this kind of
thing would be okay so we need somewhere
with abundant cheap energy but it
doesn't really matter where it is other
than that because co2 is well mixed
around the atmosphere as long as it has
access to air then it can remove co2 so
people propose ok we'll just have these
entirely automated installations and
deserts with huge solar panel arrays all
around them to satisfy the power
requirements but anything on this scale
is going to be very very expensive so if
we think about the sheer mass of co2
that we need to draw down Giga tons and
Giga tons of co2 that would be very
expensive no matter how you set up your
energy supply system so at the moment
co2 moving in the atmosphere just isn't
feasible on the scale that we're talking
about but it's definitely definitely
worth researching and hopefully sometime
in the near future new technologies will
allow it to play a significant role in
cooling the climate but what about
solution number two right so we should
think about what's going on with the
energy balance of the earth at the
moment what's happening is carbon
dioxide is reducing the amount of
radiation that the earth is emitting to
space so that means we've got a
imbalance of energy at the top of the
atmosphere and at that's causing the
plant to warm up so we need to bring
that energy balance back into balance
and one way to do that is just to reduce
the amount of energy coming in so that
then produced amount going out there's
balance by a reduced amount coming in
and so to do that we
to try and essentially dim the Sun a
couple of ways we might be able to do
that one which is extremely expensive
and probably not going to happen in them
well in this century is to launch a
constellation of satellites and space
basically just stick it in between the
earth and the Sun and so what this would
do is basically reflect a small
percentage of the sun's radiation the
only use needs to be about 1/2 percent
to achieve the kind of Cooling's of a
tenth of a degree or something that we'd
want to achieve so you could stick some
satellites in space and do it that way
but sticking everything in space is
really expensive so that probably isn't
going to work
most of the ideas grouped under solar
radiation management use what we refer
to as aerosols yes so when people think
aerosols they think the spray can stuff
right what you use forever and that's
not 100% far from the truth because when
we talk about aerosols and atmospheric
physics we talk about tiny tiny
particles in the air but we made up a
better thing so they could be small
amounts of software AG acid droplets of
sulfuric acid or they could be bits of
carbon bits of SERPs there could be
various organic compounds emitted by
plants the things that these aerosols
have in common is that they interfere
with the flow of radiation and the
energy going in out of the system so
these aerosols then act me the earth
more reflective
reducing the amount of energy that we
absorb from the Sun and so reading the
energy balance and this happens in
nature already so let's move a can
actual processes only makes sense just
on a bigger scale to produce a
significant effect so there were 1 we
could mimic volcanic eruptions which
basically emits in fact they basically
produce sulfuric acid aerosol and yes in
the stratosphere in this opera cassada
aerosol acts like a cooling haze which
reflects some sunlight or we could mimic
things like ship tracks which enhance
the brightness of clouds way down near
the surface
when you look at a satellite image of
the ocean and you can okay so if you
look at a satellite image of the ocean
and then you track where the ships go
you can see these kind of white whiter
regions where they go through the clouds
and the particulates they produce from
their chimneys basically brighten the
clouds there so we end up with brighter
marine clouds and this would also
reflect space most research has
concentrated on the first of these two
ideas and more specifically has looked
at the effects of injecting additional
aerosols into the stratosphere now as
well as being dynamically more stable
than the troposphere below it the
stratosphere has the advantage of being
almost completely dry so aerosols
injected there would stay airborne much
longer than they would in the
troposphere where they would just get
rained out now somewhat unbelievably
this is where this comes in because
we're not just limited to injecting
sulfuric acid as an aerosol we could
inject anything into the stratosphere
that produces a similar effect and what
our soul has received a lot of attention
in particular is titanium oxide titanium
titanium dioxide otherwise known as
titania is another well so you could
make an aerosol out of it it's not an
aerosol we find in great quantities
around the atmosphere at the moment
because it's basically a mineral
it's called rutile mostly and it's
actually surprisingly cheap so everyone
thinks titanium is like this really
expensive stuff titanium is titanium
dioxide is this dirty or that you find
around the globe the advantages it's
incredibly reflective so it's used in
food a lot things like toothpaste things
like aspirin and all your other white
tablets to get that nice white shininess
they use titanium dioxide so it's a 171
I think is the additive number and yeah
in theory you could grind it up and
spray it into the atmosphere and achieve
a similar cooling effect to sulfate but
with this solid particle that you can
control a lot better and is obviously a
lot more benign than cell Varick acid
geoengineering has the potential to
reverse some of the worst environmental
damage that we're doing to the planet
but doesn't fundamentally address the
root cause of the problem co2 in the
atmosphere and in addition to this it
has some downsides
one of the fundamental downsides of
using geoengineering in this manner
solar radiation management to counteract
the global one from co2 concentrations
is that if you even if you were to do it
perfectly exactly cancel out the global
average temperature change you would end
up reducing global precipitation and
that's something so there is there are
some results in climate science that
we're less sure of we're very sure of
this reduction in precipitation it
basically comes from the way that co2
affects the radiation balance of the
atmosphere relative to the way solar
radiation does basically solar radiation
doesn't get absorbed by the atmosphere
whereas co2 does this leads to a
different differential atmospheric
heating between the surface and the top
of the troposphere that affects the way
rain is formed basically you end up with
a reduction in global precipitation of
course no one ever experiences global
mean precipitation so it's very hard to
say what will happen on a more regional
scale so we tend to run some climate
model experiments of that and the
general consensus is among the climate
models is that probably there will be
some regional changes in patterns of
precipitation and bands of warm and cold
regions under geoengineering but that
actually the regional changes will
probably be smaller than the ones that
you would get under an unmitigated
global warming scenario so although
there will be regional changes if you
think about the regional changes that
you might be seeing in the future anyway
and that might not be so bad as for the
big question of whether or not we will
use geoengineering is not for me to say
I am just a Finnish D student and I
don't know everything personally I don't
think that we're going to use solar
radiation management anytime soon
there's just too many question marks
associated with it at this point
but I hope that we can use co2 and
weevil in the very near future with new
technologies now
for more information about this and the
ongoing debate about use geoengineering
stay tuned to the channel because very
soon there's gonna be video coming out
about whether the cop21 climate meeting
in Paris this December should consider
the use of geoengineering we're a bunch
of world leading academics from X to
chime in so you didn't see much mean
this video which is probably a good
thing
instead angus covered what
geoengineering is deliberately changing
the Earth's radiative properties co2
removal in the atmosphere which we'd
like to do but we can't really do it
because it's not practical yet solar
radiation management which is practical
but we're not quite sure if we'd like to
do it yet and the many issues involved
in using these techniques this was the
last video in this crash course series
on atmospheric physics and I very very
much hope that you've enjoyed it and if
you've watched many or all of the
episodes that you now feel you've got a
firmer grasp of the basics of the field
now if you have feedback on this series
please please leave that down below in
the comments I'm always trying to
improve my content so if there's stuff
that you'd liked or you didn't like
about this series say so down below and
I can try and make things better next
time if you'd like there to be a next
time and you'd like me to do more of
these kind of series then also please
PLEASE say so down in the comments and
you can suggest the topics you'd like me
to do but also if you'd like that then
the clearest message for me to do more
this kind of content in the future is
for this series and these videos to get
lots of views and to do very well so if
you want me to do more this kind of
thing please share these videos and this
the playlist of these videos to your
school's your teachers your friends and
if it does well then that says to me to
go and do more of those kind of stuff
which I'd like to do so if you'd like
that too please do share these videos
lastly if you'd like to support this
series and me more directly then you can
do so by its Connells page and if you
like the video then please do like it
and subscribe to this channel thank you
very much for watching okay so here's my
workbook it's important we're good it's
a book I like books and it's got to work
in that's my laptop which has got the
scripts with crash course videos and
that's my Japanese piece Lily always
important to keep that around because it
keeps the our oxygenated this is not the
time to change
signees interesting thing but it's off
believe you know when you're in a
negotiation say you're buying a t-shirt
or market store